oh well I can't say it wasn't an
interesting experiment I think definite
improvement clearly I mean that stuff
before yeah you know all right now
what's the idea what's the idea here's
what I'd like to put to you and I think
most of your ideas captured okay what
I'd like to suggest is there is no
multimedia that you see right which has
not been substantially persist in a way
that's not not the normal life okay a
newspaper article obviously some process
because someone had to type it on and
the typing of it is processing right
there's change okay but I mean you know
these kinds of processing things have
been adjusted example do you remember
when we were having a look at multimedia
and jobs right there was a particular
job to do with sound and a funny name
isn't ever known what it was cool what
does you with reproducing sounds and
then getting recording on a Foley artist
okay
now essentially what the Foley artists
job is through reproduce all these
sounds to press this or this sounds and
then replace the ones that are actually
there right so almost all the sounds we
hear were not captured when the thing
was being shot right even some of the
dialogue isn't there to read record
dialogue over and then persist in an
adjuster okay that was just to get your
brains going and your keyboards let's
move on what I want to try and do is
have a think about uh all of those
examples were looking at before all of
these okay can we organize them in some
way can we get some meaningful maybe I
shouldn't analyze
can we get some meaningful categories
out of these can we it's just getting
worse can we arrange them in some way
that has order and meaning to it okay so
um make a little subheading Rhonda toss
to you now two categories
Oh multimedia process okay sir let's
start with what you've got here okay all
right I'm gonna focus on these two
everything yeah I think they're a good
example and you can think of a few more
as well I'm about to give you a category
I meant it to be the second one but
since you guys have picked it I'll make
it the first one okay what's the
category that I'm talking about
it's about creative let's see well I
guess it's just for creative reasons
okay why do people put in a green screen
why do we film on top of this little
weird color what's the purpose of the
filmmaker in doing that these
suggestions thank you there's some
background or some effect perhaps that
we can't do in real life
or maybe it's hazardous to do in real
life right so what do we do our creative
reason here is to put something in we
couldn't do any other way okay and it's
the same idea with the sound okay
you know the one that always sticks in
my head is the dog that's running on the
ground and then the person has to get
like um do that paper clips on a glove
and they have to let rattle it on the
ground okay to mimic the sound of a dog
running along okay now what's the
creative reason there well the filmmaker
wants to emphasize something that can't
be captured by mobile mains right so has
to be processed and added in later okay
so creative reasons now there's tons of
these when you think of audio you can
think of a variety when you think of
images you can think of a variety okay
and when you think of video there's a
whole nother set and so that's what this
bit is about you actually went for the
second one first so I'd like you to
think of ten examples of that that's a
lot easier than it sounds
okay think about a movie you've watched
recently and just just go through it
replay the scenes in your head oh yeah
there's processing here because there
was a scene and well maybe it was CJ
maybe the whole thing
CGT that's an example okay ten examples
of that now the second one is a bit
trickier and none of you thought of
anything that goes into this category
because no one is intuitive it's not in
the background okay so here he is
category number two and I'm gonna spend
a little more time talking about this
and trying to explain okay hardware
limitations
okay now to help illustrate this well
when you do is open up Microsoft Paint
so I've already got my here okay hello
peanut makers of paint and if you
haven't already if you hidden it like me
I want you to get the the ribbon open
okay cuz we're gonna look at some things
up here once you've got it open okay you
should see up on the top right this
bunch of colors okay that bunch of
colors up there has a name do you know
remember what it's called starts with a
yeah the palette right so the analogy is
you know like a painter and he's got his
arm is palette with all the different
colors that is using right maybe he
mixes something else that's the options
he's got to paint with okay now what I
could do is um how about have a document
okay it can be blank right but what I
want you to do is go to save as
okay and you'll have a whole bunch of
different organizing options different
file types and a bitmap now we've
actually done this before but I want to
highlight something which made me do
look at that closely
I'm a tweet 4-bit bitmap change the
options and I want you to go to
monochrome okay and you can save it as
whatever you like okay now because I've
already got some stuff on my picture it
says caller qualit quality might be
reduced that's why I'm say okay now did
you see the change it was pretty I don't
know if you're paying attention
have a look at that palette what
happened my palate okay and if I what
I'm gonna do is so you can see a little
cleanup let's take a screenshot
and
okay so there's a better view of Oh what
did I just do I was a new picture okay
after we save it what's going on here
instead of my colors right this is my
new palette now it's going on okay
I chose this because you can see each
individual one this is the computer
trying to come up with patterns right
patterns are just black and white
because I said is in monochrome so black
and white it really two options I've got
these are patterns that mimic different
shades okay so for instance you know oh
that's why that's obvious and this is a
black but I believe is something like
this this is kind of 50/50 right and
then this one is more black than his
wife and this one is more white than
this black okay so this our process of
producing these patterns instead of
colors has a name it's cold and this is
my first kind of um and this is my first
kind of processing multimedia person
it's cold
did the room okay that was a little
thinner than I'm in okay now hopefully
this rings some bells okay we looked at
this very briefly reason why I'm
revisiting it is because it's a
multimedia specific thing okay now can
you see how it's connected to hardware
why do you hardware limitations or white
bar why are hardware limitations the
reason why a some software programmer
are years ago invented dithering
actually I like it wasn't a software
programmer who invented it someone think
of who else it might have been this is
around before computers a user who what
I know who's up who'd be interested in
something like this who would this be
useful for it was a type setup type
setup and what's the type setup these
are sort of um it's a job that's going
out of fashion these days but it's
someone whose job is printing basically
but when you say printer you're like hey
I'm a you know what do you do I'm a
printer but you submit that piece of
paper okay so this is a little more
helpful there's a person interesting
publishing in the written word okay now
they're interested in this because the
hardware limitations are many printers
back in the day was they could they can
print like shades and different colors
it's printed black or white right and if
you want some kind of patty you're gonna
need to do something like this okay all
right so there's one example what the
second example is one you've already
dealt with as well before it's called
compression data compression just making
it being smaller now question why is
compression connected to hardware
limitations or in what way do hardware
limitations necessitate compression
right
it's kind of like magic for us we don't
really think about it but this round
plastic and a bit of metal disc right it
stores data how much roughly that 4.7 G
I've been under five bit more than four
and a half how does it do it all these
little dots and pits that are in there
in the surface which you can't see but
that's what makes that funky reflective
pattern
okay now 4.7 bees you can't change it
you can't make it you know more people
have tried doing things like say
double-sided DVDs or multi-layer DVDs
but in the end they had to cover the
whole you stand and then we call it
blu-ray didn't always it wasn't always
that way by the way and there was a
competitive the Ray called not DVD but
HD DVD but I think it it's suffering
from a bad name because it's just too
many acronyms like hey can I get the HD
DVD this movie so anyway for my seven
gates it's all gonna fit right but let's
think about it you know when you border
if you buy a movie on TV T movie lengths
what's this choice movie you've seen
yeah I've been under one and a half
hours maybe and the longest would be
something like yeah three hours right
you're you're more of a rings --is of
the movie universe okay
now this movie and this movie gotta fit
on the same disc right and therefore
compression okay some babies you know
they try and over this never a pleasant
experience to say I'm just up to the
excite scene ejects disappoint sir okay
so therefore because there's harm a
limitation they can press things and
okay so these are two kinds of
processing for multimedia that are
driven by a totally different reason
it's not like the guys out they were
trying to be yeah let's be creative it's
so cool
let me some people do you think that
they're not usually they weren't doing
it for creative purposes I'm the same
reason like wow I really like it when I
can press things in like you lose a bit
of color quality that works so vintage
you know it's not the point
highly with quit
okay